how's it going bro my name
is welcome back to some more s this is
totally not our
house no our house looks like [__]
there's our house beautiful look at this
all right let's see what's going on
inside what's what what's your problem
Jennifer
Lopez calm down Leon
Philipus I [__] love uh Mr
sh what do you
want the [__] problem shut you clean
it you [__] clean
it all right it's time for snop to go up
that sounds really weird I
need [__] love to share it's the best
thing ever all right this is awkward and
M [__] love and
schol what what do you want
what is he doing now oh of
course I'm glad he's so easily
entertained I do that oh Mr shar's
crying come on do
something no one even cares you're all
[__] up parents all right pick up Mr
Sher teach him how to talk cuz why
not did it work
good job you made him
cry good
job she's reading a [__] book stop
make him
stop what are you doing oh that better
be
right what are you doing just talk stop
complaining and do so poor Mr
sh G of shut
up hey Mr sh
how you
doing oh he wants to
sleep I need to sell some stupid
[__] uh all right work the [__] out bro
there you go that is expensive happy
about
this all right all right it's your turn
man hey where are you
going [__] work out stop sleep why
does everyone sleep
on look they're sleeping in their bed
poor Mr
share those [__] [__] I hate all
of you you know that right [__] work
out man so fat
fast you stupid [__] come on bro you
can do better you can do better than
that all right wake the [__] up you need
to go to work I think she has a she's
she's a burglar she needs to go to work
oh he's he's awake now and happy of
course and now she's
crying that's right Mr Shar Mr Shar
knows a demon spawn whenever he sees one
all right don't touch Mr
chair can you shut the [__] up over
here all right let's play some guitar in
our bikini nice tip actually all
right sounds
wonderful Mr sh what do you think about
this Mr sh likes it what's he doing oh
he smells that's
disgusting oh no no no get out of the
bathtub that's
disgusting get
out I'm starting to wonder what her job
really
is the car is here go to work oh good
she it's totally a nice burglar
outfit all right when will we see her
again in four hours guess it's just you
and me now Mr chair since that oh
everyone is sleeping all right I guess
I'll fast forward with this [__] all
right so I think it's what what what
what what is your problem the toilet
cannot talk to
you Jesus Christ is he going to play in
the mirror I swear to God if
he
all right I think he's ready to go out
and hit the town and get some
ladies all right here we go why is he
running all of a sudden where are you
going why the rush bro all right there's
got to be some ladies up in
here scanning for
ladies scanning for
girls it's literally [__] empty
are you kidding me all right is that a
girl I think we spotted poine van oh sit
this is going to be so
awkward ah it's
perfect come on Jesus Christ I ain't got
all day all right you got you
smelled who's doing that
noise sounds like someone is [__]
he really is that all you
got you're so awkward oh no now he's
going to steal your girl not not on my
watch I'm here for you bro and no [__]
now she leaves all right here's your
[__] what is she doing she got home
from work it's too early oh it's a
[__]
boy it really is that damn damn damn why
is there no people here here
me what do we have here what do we have
here Abraham
frinkle perfect
girl all
right isn't that a boy's
name no just go there go there if you
want to hit on
there come on
dude o
hello it's is that a boy or a girl
hello what we totally missed the Hy
godam
it oh no it's a
boy oh man all right so
romantic
H he doesn't even like it dude I'm not
gay hey come on have you seen my face
paint how can you not like this have you
seen my giant smokes of fume coming out
of my
a God damn it he thinks I am a
Nuance hello very M all right all right
all right all right here we go yes
yes oh come on you're so awkward she
made 100 and one that's [__]
it okay all right this better be
good what is the name
bab all right so be
funny tell a funny story mhm
uhuh magnor oh the story about magnor is
the best [__]
ever what stupid [__] we're gonna go
over to Jennifer Jennifer what's
up what she
doing
okay I love Mr
share what what is he doing that and
don't put him to oh well I guess it's
late
finally so let's see how it's going over
here is he getting any
luck what is he
doing oh forever alone drinking a glass
of milk in the midd in an afternoon in
the park because why not are you
enjoying
that have you had fun today I think it's
time to go home Jennifer I don't know
what you're thinking about but she's got
and steal
something okay Mr sh okay uh call the
babysitter where is she
going she's going to go and steal where
oh over at the beach well this could be
trauma
what oh he passing her what is she
do what is she doing she's not stealing
anything what is this drink a
drink nla viser what do he want he wants
to sleep well [__] go to sleep then I
don't
care another glass of milk what is up
with this family and milk in
park I did not tell her to go here like
what the [__] Miss sh all right we're
going to kill Lopez cuz I'm tired of her
[__] all right and you go Lopez but
never come back the doll uh oh where is
it yes yes burn
Lopez burn
Jennifer why isn't she burning well
that's nice Mr sh is enjoying himself at
oh no he's crying what do you want why
why why do
something
pick him
up are you dead yet well that [__]
demon spawn just won't die won't you
guess we have to try a new new thing huh
there we go enjoy it
Lopez I want to see her
suffer what is she
doing she's having spasm so he's
enjoying a good night's sleep what is a
miss share P out on the floor how could
you do that are you enjoying
yourself good cuz now now he has slept
and he needs
to needs to hang out with some ladies go
there Mr
Shar go you go oh he smells that's
disgusting even the mailman is like what
the [__] that really smells all right
you died die die die what what's your
problem
Lopez all right so she will drown in 14
minutes all right let's count it
that Mr sh loves it 10 9 8 7 6 5 4
3 2 one she's
dead yes
yes yes
waa W who are you what the
[__] no what is
happening what in the hell H where's the
car oh she needs to go to
[Music]
work a part Mr Shar oh he's sucking in
her soul can Mr Shar talk to
[Music]
him
can we the Sher direct with him no he
can't oh Lopez what's going on
Lopez Mr Shar is like sup well what's up
with this responsible snob where is he
now where is he
now I'm
single this
was this
was
[Music]
I came what is Mrs Shar
doing a he's all oh he still likes it oh
is going on here who the [__] are you
David
sinel oh you son of a
[__] what is your
problem poor Mr
chair do
something what is he going to do oh he
gave him food
good that's
nice this irresponsible snap obviously
don't give a [__] I mean he's [__]
women I
don't that [__] laugh he's really out
of shape aren't you oh no I'm so
fat she's fondu she's fondu I never triy
that he going to TI rub her what is
wrong with everyone chill
all right Bros I think that'll be it for
this episode but luck and favor if you
enjoyed subscribe to come today and I'll
see you next time let me know what if
you want me to do any more of these feel
like I'm kind of I don't really know
what the [__] to do in this game I guess
I could download a expansion pack uh or
some [__] like that anyway
that's he grabs in the
background uh click PewDiePie what does
he
do
you're
B you [__]
B